I do hereby declare that Michael John
wood is duly elected
[Applause]
while I won't speak long because I'm
only waiting here the declarations but
just a few thank-yous first of all I'd
like to thank the returning officer and
all of these staff both both this
evening and throughout the day operating
selection so so smoothly and getting a
result in a little earlier than than
expected like to thank the police for
keeping us safely campaign but
particularly this evening
over the past few weeks of course if we
ever needed any reminder of the
importance but also the danger
associated with their work those
reminders have becomingly the most
tragic forms but of course most of all I
would like to thank my family for their
support
it's not always easy I've been living
with a politician it's certainly not
easy living with it with a member of
parliament I think it's safe to say that
this year hasn't been quite what my wife
would probably over expected them in
terms of in terms of my health and then
a general election campaign to the top
funding for all of us who who stand for
public office or indeed who get involved
in community politics the constant and
day-to-day support of our families is
what allows us to keep on going and is
really the rock on which you and our
rest and I'd also of course like to
thank all of the people who worked so
hard over the last seven weeks to build
this campaign from something of a
surprise start to delivering an
increased majority increased number of
bodom increased sheriff vote in Douglas
and it's been a tremendous honor to to
serve people don't miss out the last two
years and on
honestly grateful to the voters of
Dudley sanity put their trust in me
today to serve them for another five
years to work for the community and
finally I'm actually probably most
significantly evolved course I'd like to
face special thanks to the doctors the
nurses and all of the staffers at
Russell's Hall who saved my life in
January it means that I can be standing
here at all yet alone standing for
election
elections inevitably focus on
differences between people that I think
particularly looking at the word both in
the coronary care unit particularly
intensive therapy units versus muscles
or their work through day and night was
absolutely extraordinary and so I will
always we literally owe my life to to
their work so I won't keep you any
longer just anyone I may have forgotten
I'm sure I have a an opportunity to
thank either later tonight or perhaps
over the weekend in one of our local
establishments so thank you very much